inject me with another episode of Silo
we are more than halfway there to the
ending with three episodes to go and I'm
still scratching my head at what exactly
is going on in this video we take a look
at the show's Biggest Mysteries Clues
and theories and don't worry if you
haven't read the book I haven't either
this is a non-spoiler review as always
I've left timestamps below so you can
see all the topics I'll be covering Now
put on your suits it's time to clean we
begin on the beaches of Georgia or
should I say a hallucination of them
these are images directly from the
Amazing Adventures in Georgia book
complete with the nautilus shell one
found in the book and also tattooed on
George Gloria Hildebrandt George's Aunt
hallucinates a Life by the ocean with
the husband and daughter but just like
the ocean is a figment of Her
Imagination so too is her daughter
Gloria never had kids as we'll learn
throughout the episode she like Alison
were tricked into believing they were
infertile with Juliet's father Dr
Nicholas feels complicit in the cover-up
Dr Nichols never removed Gloria's birth
control this was a part of some grander
plan to keep those Silo goers who asked
too many questions from procreating and
Dr Nichols never questioned this because
he knows what happens to those who ask
too many questions if the silo is some
sort of experiment perhaps this idea of
obedience is at its core is it all some
test to create the most obedient humans
a test that will take years to weed out
the ones that ask too many questions
this is also where we're introduced to
the flame Keepers a group of individuals
intent on preserving the memories and
history of the pre-silo world according
to Gloria she is the last flame keeper
left passing the Baton off to Juliet she
even hints that Juliet's mother Hannah
was close to the flame Keepers but not
necessarily one of them Hannah worked
with Anne George's mother in creating a
magnifying device we learned from Martha
about this device a few episodes ago and
and that it was ultimately retrieved by
judicial for violating the Pax rule of
no magnification Beyond a certain power
glorious hallucinations are not brought
upon by dementia as Nurse Amy describes
but by her being drugged up on Lorazepam
someone is wanting to keep her drugged
and thus not a problem with Sims and the
Watchers keeping tabs on her they are
likely the culprits the episode also
gives us some more names inside the
front cover of the book which may or may
not be past flame Keepers there's Blau
tea Emilio c o b i j and Melody but it's
rather odd as some of the letters are
capitalized some are not and some are
written in cursive it kind of reminds me
of the word truth engraved on holston's
badge and for some reason the T and the
H are capitalized here well our poor guy
Lucas tries making a move on Juliet and
is shut down denied I wouldn't put him
in the friend zone just yet I mean
Juliet has a lot going on and she just
found out that the love of her life was
is using her so she probably has a lot
of feelings going on now there are a few
interesting bits of information here
first Juliet connects the lights in the
sky with being stars as evidenced with
that page in her book perhaps by knowing
the placement of these constellations
they can determine where they are on
earth there's also mention of a comet or
shooting star which may help them figure
out when they are for example Haley's
Comet appears every 76 years if they
know what Lucas saw they could infer
what year it is we also learned that
Lucas is a systems analyst that works in
it that could definitely come in handy
especially considering the discovery of
the hard drive at the end of the episode
I think we'll see Lucas and Juliet
working together and just a reminder if
you like these types of videos take a
moment to like And subscribe it really
helps the channel out Bernard's becoming
more and more of an ally for Juliet but
I'm still wary of his intentions he'll
tell Juliet that judge Meadows
threatened to remove him after he's
sided with Juliet last episode episode
on the George investigation mayor
Bernard thinks that Meadows is making a
move to hijack the silos servers as a
former head of it he knows just how
important those servers are they control
everything from the ventilation crops
and messages so he wants to work with
Juliet to keep Meadows at Bay but
something seems very off with the judge
last episode we saw how she was under
the weather and now she's off work due
to a quote-unquote cold Juliet believes
Meadows is purposely holding Gloria
against her will but when she mentions
Gloria Meadows at first doesn't even
know who she is I think that's because
Meadows is merely a puppet doing the
bidding of a higher power when Juliet
makes an offer to give up being sheriff
in exchange for a few hours with Gloria
the judge says it's not possible but
never explains why just stating that
quote they'll never let you who are
these people it's either Sims or some
other power then there's also the
question of meadows's sickness which
Juliet says is quote just as real as
Gloria's Dimension what did she mean by
this does Meadows have something more
than a cold she kind of moves this white
bottle when Juliet arrives is that
alcohol after all Juliet tells her to
quote keep drinking her cold medicine I
just found it rather odd regardless it
seems as though Meadows is merely a
puppet doing what Sims wants in exchange
for this fancy apartment and to keep
some relics we get confirmation that
Sims is the boss of not just two of
these Watchers but several they keep
constant surveillance Over The Silo
through various cameras embedded into
mirrors Holston somehow knew about this
hence why he left flowers in front of
Juliet's mirrors the vase of which is
conveniently destroyed by maintenance in
order to allow them a better view of her
apartment but we also learned that
Holston placed flowers in Gloria's room
too it's almost as though Juliet is
following holston's breadcrumbs but the
question remains whether or not this
will end up with her cleaning as well
this episode also gives us more insight
site into the relationship between
Juliet and her father he's quite excited
when she arrives on his doorstep stating
that he's waited a long time to tell her
something he actually never gets a
chance to tell her what this is but it's
safe to say it involves something to do
with her mother at the end of the
episode we learned that Hannah Juliet's
mother killed herself and I can't help
but think Juliet believes her father was
somehow responsible after all he has a
history of not coming through and Juliet
implies he somehow betrayed Hannah we
also get some more info as to what
happened to Juliet's brother Jacob in
episode 4 when Gloria experiences a
seizure Dr Nichols tells Juliet quote
you know what to do suggesting she had
been through this before with Jacob did
Jacob eventually succumb to these
seizures and is that part of why Hannah
killed herself and finally we're
reintroduced to George's hard drive
which Holston took all the way back in
episode 2. just to see stash documents
in his apartment vent so too does he
stash the hard drive in event and now we
get into our trailer sleuthing segment
where we take a look at the trailers to
see if we can uncover any new Clues just
a reminder we won't be covering every
clip just the ones that pertain to new
information we received this episode
well it looks as though Bernard is
brought into the Janitor's Closet which
really puts a question mark on whose
side he's really on later we'll see him
in a corn field telling what might be
Juliet that the clock is running there
isn't much time left before she gets
tackled by one of those SWAT members so
I'm curious as to which side Bernard is
really on here we have Juliet hiding in
a hospital-like setting which may be her
escape from the long-term care facility
since next episode is titled Hannah
after Juliet's mother it looks as though
we'll be getting to see that magnifying
device she created alongside George's
mother Anne not sure what this device is
but it has the number 18 on it which was
the same number found on the hard drive
in episode 1. Juliet's here perhaps at
Lucas's it desk hooking the hard drive
up to a computer now it's time I turn it
over to you what do you think will
happen next I want to hear in the
comments below thanks for watching
please make sure to like And subscribe
and for more bad takes you can follow me
on Twitter and Instagram at thinkstory
YT until next time remember
explain keep